[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos
lleva a egipto específicamente a la
emblemática plaza tahrir en el cairo la
capital del país el 25 de enero de 2011
decenas de miles de egipcios se dieron
cita en este lugar para exigir la
destitución del presidente hosni mubarak
quien llevaba 30 años en el poder la
desigualdad la pobreza la corrupción y
la violencia policial hicieron que la
ira de la población creciera a pesar de
los violentos enfrentamientos entre las
fuerzas del orden y los manifestantes
que dejaron cerca de 1000 muertos más de
8000 heridos cada vez más personas se
unieron al movimiento a los slogans de
pan libertad y justicia social tras 18
días de ocupación de la plaza
mubarak anuncia su dimisión una victoria
efímera que hoy en día tiene un gusto
amargo para muchos egipcios diez años
después cómo se encuentra el país bajo
el mandato de abdel fatal si si la
situación es igual o mejor que como
barack que quedan de las esperanzas
revolucionarias
[Música]
la plaza tahrir aquí latía el corazón de
la revolución egipcia hace diez años hoy
en día las aglomeraciones al igual que
las cámaras están prohibidas solid toma
fue una revolucionaria desde el primer
momento
y había carpas en todas partes sobre
todo alrededor de la plaza por allá
había diferentes campamentos recuerdo
que todos los días nos visitábamos a las
seis de la tarde hablábamos de band y
amos y discutíamos aquí vivía el momento
más feliz de mi vida hace diez años
una magia que duró poco dos años después
los militares regresan al poder gracias
a una nueva insurrección dirigida esta
vez contra los hermanos musulmanes que
acaban de ser elegidos en el gobierno
el nuevo hombre fuerte de egipto abdel
fatal si si aparece en todos los muros
lord shen es duro muchas cosas pasaron
después simplemente para robarse la
revolución rápidamente más ya fueran los
hermanos musulmanes o los militares
brocheta el fracaso de la revolución
traumatizó a una parte de la juventud en
estos tiempos de pandemia la psiquiatra
hace consultas desde su casa a menudo
los pacientes son antiguos manifestantes
de la plaza tahrir que resienten sus
sueños frustrados
en los últimos 10 años han sido
particularmente traumáticos porque todo
este lugar es un terreno traumático
y en todas partes está la sensación de
la derrota esto así que el trauma esté
más presente y pueda sentirse es difícil
pero seguimos adelante sigo adelante con
todas las cicatrices y las heridas en la
medida
es mucho espacio para hacer 'borrón y
cuenta nueva'
el presidente sisi decidió desplazar las
instituciones a su nueva capital en este
vídeo de publicidad la empresa encargada
de su construcción controlada por el
ejército presume una ciudad conectada
protegida ecológica que debería
descongestionar a el cairo poblada por
20 millones de personas esta nueva
ciudad surgida de la arena debería tener
siete veces el tamaño de parís y acoger
a más de 6 millones de habitantes
el presupuesto 52 mil millones de euros
para desplazar el corazón del poder
este funcionario es el encargado de
mostrarnos el avance de las obras
el nuestro hace dos años aquí no había
absolutamente nada hoy en día pueden ver
el ministerio de transporte de salud de
vivienda de trabajo y aquí el consejo de
ministros todo el mundo trabaja de
manera asidua para respetar los
ajustados plazos y seguir las órdenes
del presidente su fe es una construcción
sin precedentes en el país jamás hemos
visto algo así
el orgullo del presidente es la torre
iconic una vez terminado con sus 385
metros y sus 80 pisos este rascacielos
será el más alto de áfrica
es la primera vez que se construye una
torre tan grande en egipto es el signo
de la grandeza del gobierno esta nueva
capital es un megaproyecto era necesaria
una torre como ésta
[Música]
junto a estos sueños desmesurados la
triste realidad de egipto se lee en los
reportes de las organizaciones de
defensa por los derechos humanos cada
vez más abrumadores
detenciones arbitrarias torturas
condenas a muerte ha aparecido un nuevo
fenómeno preocupante las desapariciones
forzosas
los egipcios dicen que son guardan el
sam's literalmente desaparecidos detrás
del sol
mohamed fi es defensor de los derechos
humanos le brinda un apoyo jurídico a
las familias aquí se reúne con saimaa
fifa
su esposo ex diputado de la oposición
fue condenado en 2017 por injuria al
sistema judicial estaba esperando la
apelación del veredicto inicial cuando
desapareció eso fue hace más de dos años
shaima está desesperada
le envío este mensaje a quien sea que
esté detrás de la desaparición de
mustafa quiero que lo entienda con
claridad sus hijos lo necesitan
no sé por qué está detenido desaparecido
pero imaginemos que hizo algo estoy
segura de que lo podemos arreglar
solamente necesitamos que nos dejen
contactarlo
hubo 70 de año desde 2014
la organización de mohamed lotfi han
registrado 2 mil 700 desapariciones para
él hay dos razones para esta práctica
a la comida es un sendero de disparos
la primera es mantener a ese
desaparecido sin protección jurídica
alguna y poder torturarlo a voluntad de
ese torch o la hace esas torturas sirven
para provocar que la persona se empiece
o simplemente para humillarla como la
segunda razón y es más política es
propagar e infundir el miedo entre la
sociedad
difícil la prueba o la société
a 9000 kilómetros de el cairo mohamed
zoltan reconstruye su vida en las
afueras de washington
en 2013 su universo dio un vuelco
mientras documentaba una agrupación de
los hermanos musulmanes reprimida con
violencia
varios centenares de personas habrían
muerto el padre de mohamed asociado con
el grupo islamista fue condenado a
cadena perpetua mohamed estuvo
encarcelado durante casi tres años para
denunciar las violencias del sistema
carcelario este estadounidense egipcio
hizo una huelga de hambre durante
cuatrocientos ochenta y nueve días
es difícil hablar sobre la tortura puedo
hablar sobre eso pero es difícil porque
el dolor físico que uno recuerda termina
por desaparecer desaparece como cuando
uno se quiebra con un brazo y el dolor
físico se va lo que permanece siempre la
tortura psicológica
cinco años después aún vivo con eso
the fire sliders tv
para mohamed el responsable es hazem el
beblawi primer ministro egipcio en la
época de su detención en junio pasado-
mohamed zoltan puso una denuncia en su
contra ante la justicia estadounidense
por tortura y tentativas de homicidio
esta es una de las decisiones más
importantes de mi vida
es una documentación legal de 47 páginas
con todo lo que me ocurrió y todos los
detalles de las violaciones y las
torturas que me hicieron
el di
al demandar al ex primer ministro
mohamed sol tan se enfrenta a un sistema
entero una decisión que implica riesgos
tras esta demanda las autoridades
egipcias detuvieron a cinco de sus
primos que pasaron más de cuatro meses
en la cárcel antes de ser recientemente
liberados
toma como rehenes a los familiares de
los activistas del exilio para tratar de
silenciar espero que sí sí se ha
condenado en una corte internacional por
el crimen que ha cometido contra su
pueblo en el equipo
en este muro están los nombres de más de
7000 personas detenidas entre 2019 y
2020 desde que se votó una ley
antiterrorista en 2015 las razones que
dan las autoridades siempre son las
mismas pertenencia a un grupo terrorista
y difusión de informaciones falsas
es bajo esas dos acusaciones que la gran
mayoría de los prisioneros políticos son
detenidos de manera provisional sin
proceso durante meses y años
podemos discernir
mohamed loft y considera que el gobierno
abusa de su poder en nombre de la lucha
antiterrorista
tener una opinión diferente sobre el
gobierno y expresarla en egipto sitúa a
las personas en la categoría de
terroristas eso empezó en 2013 en la
detención de los manifestantes a favor
de amor si el antiguo presidente ahora
difunto
y ahora llegamos al punto en el que
ciudadanos comunes y corrientes sin
pertenencias políticas son tratados
igual que los prisioneros políticos
detenidos en masa trata manías y están
detenidos en condiciones inhumanas
y
desde condiciones
durante una conferencia de prensa le
pedimos al ministro egipcio de asuntos
exteriores que respondiera a estas
acusaciones sameh shukri las niega sin
vacilación
[Música]
algunas organizaciones favorecen la
violencia y el extremismo y tienen
vínculos muy importantes con los medios
arturo garcía siller estaba solo
estas organizaciones de defensa de los
derechos vehicular ideas falsas que no
son nada acordes con la realidad
y no somos en vídeos como éste enviados
a los periodistas el ministerio de la
información defiende la evaluación del
gobierno y culpa a los hermanos
musulmanes por alegaciones consideradas
mentirosas en particular en relación con
las desapariciones forzosas
[Música]
egipto hace todo lo posible por elevar
la sociedad egipcia y enfrentar sus
obligaciones constitucionales en el
ámbito de los derechos humanos
a pesar de las afirmaciones del gobierno
según amnistía internacional al menos
60.000 personas están detenidas en
egipto por razones políticas
aquí en el corazón del poder
estadounidense mohamed zoltan ha
declarado en varias ocasiones delante de
los miembros del congreso
el régimen continúa escalando su
represión de una manera que no tiene
precedentes
y eso ocurre porque no está enfrentando
ninguna consecuencia real por escalar
esa represión
es como si la comunidad internacional
estuviera dando luz verde para que haga
lo que quiera
wisin la administración de joe biden
promete ser más firme en cuanto al
respeto de los derechos humanos en
egipto entre tanto mohamed zoltan está
frustrado al ver que su país sigue
siendo un aliado privilegiado de las
diplomacias occidentales sí sí no habría
sobrevivido tanto como lo ha hecho si no
estuviera respaldado y si no fuera
bienvenido en lugares como este en la
casa blanca en el elíseo y en otros
lugares en diciembre pasado el
presidente sisi recibió la legión de
honor de las mismas manos del presidente
de francia emmanuel macrón un
certificado de legitimidad otorgado al
régimen
para sobrevivir los opositores ahora
deben escoger exiliarse o callarse
[Aplausos]
[Música]
llegamos al final de boleto de vuelta a
plaza tarija los invito a visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
para ver este y otros contenidos en
español hasta pronto
[Música]